fox news alert now chicago teachers
union members are voting to continue to
work from home
due to coronavirus safety concerns now
this move goes
against the city's plan to reopen public
schools for in-person learning
garrett tenney he's live in chicago
garrett what happens to classes
this week if teachers don't show up
well dana the union says if chicago
public schools tries to force its
teachers back into the classroom
they will go on strike schools are
scheduled to reopen to in-person
learning
a week from today and the district
ordered teachers to be in their physical
classrooms
this week to get ready to welcome
students back but
in a closer than normal union vote
sunday 71 percent voted to reject the
district's demands
after the vote ctu president jesse
sharkey said the overwhelming majority
of our members have chosen
safety unity and solidarity and an
agreement is within reach but we need a
willing partner
the union doesn't want to return to
in-person learning until
all teachers are vaccinated despite
local state and federal health officials
saying
schools can operate safely with
appropriate precautions in place
but cps says grades attendance and
enrollment has dropped significantly for
students over the past few months
and they need to be back in the
classroom to keep things from getting
worse
many parents and students agree
they have all f's and that is not
typical for my children i am seeing
increasing anxiety and depression in all
three of my children
the disruption of a strike to these
vulnerable children
is traumatizing and will impact their
education and mental health i need a
break from my mom
i just need to go back to school
the covet situation in chicago has been
steadily improving this weekend
restaurants reopened for indoor
dining and starting today teachers in
illinois are eligible to receive the
first dose
of the vaccine so far both the chicago
teachers union and chicago public
schools say
negotiations are ongoing but if no deal
is reached by wednesday
teachers could officially go on strike
dana
the kids they really do want to go back
to school thank you